WHAT TO CALL TO ORDER THIS
HEARING OF THE BUDGETS OF --
BUDGET THIS BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WELL WELCOME EVERYONE HERE TODAY --
TODAY ESSENTIALLY IS -- ARE VOTE
ONLY A CALENDAR FOR THE ITEMS AS
WE WRAP UP OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THERE IS NO --
PUBLIC COMMENT JUST TO BE CLEAR
ON THIS -- AT THIS HEARING I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE -- BEFORE WE BEGIN I ALSO
WANT.
TO THANK ALL OF THEM MY FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
CENTER STONE CENTER TADO THE
HARD WORK ON THIS COMMITTEE I
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR STAFF --
BOTH THE DEMOCRATIC STAFF --
SCOTTO GETS ME TO POKE AND
REPUBLICAN STAFF -- ANTHONY
ARCHIE AND REBEKAH HAMILTON
BECAUSE I KNOW ALL OF YOU HAVE
NOT ONLY WORKED HARD OUTSIDE THE
HEARINGS UT HAVE STAYED IN THIS
ROOM FOR SOME VERY EXTENDED
HEARINGS AND AND AND FOR
IMPORTANT COMMENTS I ALSO WANT
TO I DO RECOGNIZE AND AND SEE.
MEMBERS OF THE LA -- AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I KNOW YOU TO
OF HUNG OUT WITH US AS WELL FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME.
IN ADDITION OF COURSE TO ALL THE
AGENCY FOLKS AT THE COME TESTIFY
I'M SURE THAT WAS THE HIGHLY
THEIR DAY TO COME AND TESTIFY
HERE.
SO.
WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD BEGIN
THEIR GENDER WHICH THEN -- WILL
HELP.
WRAP UP OUR TO GEN -- PROPOSALS --
THEN THAT WILL GO TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
SO WE WILL START OFF WITH PART A
AND WE'RE GONNA DO THESE -- THE
DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT AND
WILL TAKE THEM UP AS CONSENT
CALENDAR AND AND THEN CENTER.
STONE CAN INDICATE WHICH ONCE OR
SENATOR TADO SHE MAY HAVE SOME
OPINIONS TO SEE WHAT'S THE
EXTRACT ANYTHING AS A FROM THAT
CONSENT FOUNDER -- FOR
INDIVIDUAL -- CONSIDERATION FOR
VOTING OKAY SO STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY OH FIVE THREE OO.
WE HAVE ISSUE TO NUMBER ONE CAL
HERE'S SYSTEM INTEGRATOR
CONTRACT CONDITION ACTIVITIES --
WHICH IS APPROVED IS BUDGETED WE
HAVE THE MEDI CAL EDGELL COLLEGE
BILLY DATA SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
PROJECT MULTI DEPARTMENT TEAM --
WHICH IS THE RECOMMENDED FOR
APPROVAL WITH ADOPTION OF
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE --
TO REQUIRE FALLING PRIOR TO
EXPENDITURE FUNDING ON FACE TO
THE BONE IMPORTATION ACTIVITIES --
THAT -- THEY HAVE APPROVAL OF
THE STATE'S STREETS SAFE FOR
DOCUMENTS RIGHT FARM TECHNOLOGY.
AND NOTIFICATION JOINT ALLEGEDLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE ISSUE NUMBER
THREE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION FACE TO PLANNING.
AS APPROVED BUDGETED STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION AS RECOMMENDED
PROVE HIS BUDGETING LIVES THAT
PROVES BUDGETING HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION.
IS APPROVED HIS BUDGET IN THE
TOP PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO AMEND TITLE
RESPONSIBLY FOR THE COUNCIL TO
LINE WITH THE NEW TITLE SINGLE
PAYER ORIENTATION OF THE HEALTHY.
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION --
ISSUE NUMBER SIX STATE
VERIFICATION HELP PLAN
ACTIVITIES AS APPROVE THIS
BUDGET IN A TOP PLACEHOLDER
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE --
TO REQUEST THAT MAJOR AUTOMATION
PROJECTS SOME RICE COMMUNICATING
IT TO TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- THE CURRENT BASICALLY
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND ROAD MAP --
CALL CAL QUALITY CARE DOT ORG --
IS -- RECOMMEND APPROVAL OF THE
ANNUAL EXIT AN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY -- FROM THE OFFICE OF
PATIENT ADVOCATE TRUST FUND OF
HALF MILLION ANNUALLY TO OPERATE
THE CAL QUALITY ORG -- WEBSITE
THROUGH THE OFFICE PATIENTS HAVE
ADVOCATE CONTRACTIONS UCSF -- SO
THOSE ARE THE ITEMS UNDER COVER
ARE YOU RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST WE PULL ITEM FIVE AND
MOVED THE BALANCE.
OKAY SO WHAT WE ARE EXTRACTING
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE REMAINDER
OF THE CONSENT TELLERS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STONE --
ACTUALLY NOT BEFORE WE VOTE I DO
NEED TO BE SURE WE STILL WISH
QUORUM SO SECRETARY -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR RECEPTION CORN
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HERE.
STONE.
OKAY DON'T WANT TO START TAKING
BILLS WITHOUT DOING THAT.
SO WE NOW HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- FOR THIS --
EXTRACTING ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CAN I STONE.
OKAY.
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE UP SSUE
NUMBER -- FIVE MISTER MOTION --
FOR ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FALL
COMMISSION.
WHEN WE BY CENTER TADO
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL?
HI FOR TITLE STONE.
OKAY.
SO THAT IS OUT TO WHAT.
EXTENT BECAUSE OUT THREE ZERO
OKAY SO NEXT.
ITEM IS CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
JUST ONLY -- ONE ISSUE.
YES.
AND THAT IS -- THE ALIGNMENT
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY.
THEY GET THE RIGHT YES -- THE
LINE OF EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
FOR CHILDREN MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS SERVICES AND THAT'S
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR REAPPROPRIATION OF
FUNDING TO LINE REMOVED.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR STONE --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI DONNA STONE.
THAT IS OUT THREE ZERO TAXES
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
ALREADY -- ISSUE WAS EMT
CERTIFICATION THE NILE REPORTING
IS FOR THIS BUDGETED.
ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO IS --
AMBULANCE PATIENT OFF LOW TIME
REPORTING AND IT'S MOVE THIS
AFTER THIS BUDGET -- ISSUE
NUMBER THREE CHILD CARE PROVIDER
LEAD POISONING TRAINING AND THE
RECOGNITION IS -- APPROVES
BUDGET IS ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
INDIVIDUAL TAX ID FOR EMT
CERTIFICATION THAT'S WITH HIS
APPROVED THIS BUDGET.
IN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT COSTS AND
THAT'S ALSO THE PROOF IS
BUDGETED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WE PULL ITEM
ONE IN FOUR MOVE THE BONES OKAY
SO WE ARE EXTRACTING ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IN ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
AND ITS THE ISSUES TWO THREE AND
FIVE HAVE BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI -- TACO STONE.
THOSE ARE OUT TO THREE ZERO
LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE ONE RIGHT.
YES YES ISSUE NUMBER ONE YES
ISSUE NUMBER ONE UNDER EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES STORY -- THIS
EMT CERTIFICATION THE NILE
REPORTING IS OUR MOTION.
THAT CREATES A NEW BY SENATOR
TADO THE SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AM I RIGHT OR TITLE.
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT TWO ONE X. IS
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR INDIVIDUAL TAX
ID NUMBER FOR EMT CERTIFICATION
MOTION MOVED WITH LASSITER TADO
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL AM I
RIGHT OR TITLE.
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE OKAY NEXT IT IS --
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY WITH THE PART PUBLIC
HEALTH THE STATE HOUSE THE
PHARMACY HOSPITALS DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES.
IF YOU WANT TO IS ASTROPECTEN
HIS RESPONSE AND RECOVERY SOME
OF OKAY IT'S RIGHT.
MOVED -- BY CENTER SINCE THEIR
SON GOT IN JUST A LITTLE FASTER --
THAT SECRETARY -- PLEASE GOOD
ACTUALLY ON TO THE OKAY SO
THAT'S APPROVED BUDGETED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI THE TOTAL STONE.
OKAY SO THAT'S OUT.
THREE ZERO OKAY NEXT UP IS --
OFFICE IS THE WHITE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AND SO
WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER ONE MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WHICH IS A PREVIOUS BUDGET WITH
AND ADOPT PLACEHOLDER BILL
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO SET
ASIDE ONE MILLION OF FUNDING FOR
TARGET LOAN REPAYMENT.
AS FOR FORMER FOSTER YOU SERVICE
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THAT'S BEEN A
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
FIVE YEAR PLAN THAT PRUE'S
EXPENDITURES STORY FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND OF
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO FUND WHAT
PROGRAMS IN A TOP PLACE HOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRED
EQUIVALENT CONTRIBUTION COUNTY
MATCHING FUNDS. TO COUNTIES
WHICH WHAT PROGRAMS WE FUNDED BY
THIS AUGMENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE REVERSION OF
EXCESS FUNDING FOR ALL PLAYERS
PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE -- THE
MOTION.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVED VERSION OF THE FIFTY
MILLION OF GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE APPROVED A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
AND HOSPITAL REMAIN TEN MILLION
OF GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK DEVELOPING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REVIEW COMMITTEE
AND SO -- AND THEN ISSUE NUMBER
FOR PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIPS --
THIS IS A RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND OF TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
FOR AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FOR SCHOLARSHIPS. TO PAY TUITION
FOR IN A ONE YEAR FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER TRAINING ESSENTIALS OF
PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRY
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROPOSAL.
THIS ORDER RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
WITH PAUL ITEM THREE AND MOVED
THE BALANCE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE EXPECTING
ISSUE NUMBER THREE AND OF CENTER
SO IS MOVED ISSUE ONE TWO AND
FOUR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T KNOW STONE.
HI OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE RIVERS OF
EXCESS FUNNY FOR ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE AS OUR MOTION.
BY SENATOR TADO SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THEM HI YOUR TOTAL.
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TWO ZERO OKAY.
NEXT UP IS THE PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THERE ARE FIFTY
ISSUES THERE SO GIVE ME A MOMENT
HERE.
OKAY SO ISSUE NUMBER ONE MEDI
CAL LOCAL ASSISTANT ESTIMATE MAY
REVISION UPDATE -- THAT'S PROOF --
IS BUDGETED.
IF YOU CHOOSE FAMILY HEALTH
ESTIMATE MAY VERSION UPDATE --
THAT IS ALSO -- PROOF AS BUDGET --
ISSUE NUMBER THREE FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL EXPANSION TO YEAH
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS
RECOMMENDATION IS.
ACTUALLY -- TO FOR SEVERAL SO
THAT.
RECOMMENDATIONS -- SEPARATE
RECOMMENDATION SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE AT PROVE F. EXPENDITURE
THIRTY OF NINETY EIGHT MILLION
FOR EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE
MEDICARE COVERAGE DUNDALK MANY
OUNG ADULTS AGE.
NINETEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
EFFECTIVE JERRY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY APPROVED ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF SIXTY
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION TO EXPAND
FULL SCOPE MEDICARE COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS AGE SIXTY
FIVE AND OVER EFFECTIVE JERRY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY UP TOP PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE EMPLOYMENT
EXPANSION A FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE TO A DOCUMENT YOUNG
ADULTS AND SENIORS EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY DOCTOR TAYLOR'S
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE INCREASE ELIGIBILITY
FOR FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL FOR AND
DOCUMENT INDVIDUALS ONE YEAR
EVERY FISCAL YEAR BEGINNING WITH
THE EXPANSION TO INDIVIDUALS AGE
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ADOPT A SOLDIER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE APPROVED ADMINISTRATION
UPDATED MAY REVISION TRAILER
PROPOSAL.
REDUCTION FOR REDIRECTION OF
COUNTY REALIGNMENT FUNDING
IMPROVE HIS BUDGET TO POSITIONS
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
660-024-0004 BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION EXPANSION OF FULL
SCOPE MEDICARE COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR MANAGE CARE
AND ROMAN TAX -- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE
ADICIONAL GENERAL FUND OFFSETS
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM OF ONE
POINT THREE SEVEN THREE BILLION
AND TO TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND ONE POINT EIGHT THREE ONE
BILLION IN. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
212-021-22020 TWO AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXTEND THE MANAGED
CARE ROMAN TAX UPDATED TO
REFLECT MORE CURRENT ROMAN
ENROLLMENT DATE AN ADJUSTED
ACCORDINGLY TO MAXIMIZE FUNDING
FOR THE MEDICARE PROGRAM FILL
FEDERAL REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE PROP FIFTY SIX
INVESTMENTS -- THE RIVER
[inaudible]
THOSE.
ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE. TWO
X. APPROVE EXPENDITURE THIRTY
TWO POINT ONE BILLION -- IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWO POINT TWO BILLION.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER PAYMENTS
IN MEDICARE.
ADULT PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING DTS TO SEEK A
THREE YEAR STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
ALL SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER
PAYMENTS IN BOTH FEE FOR SERVICE
AND MANAGE CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
A MEDI CAL.
APPROVED TOTAL EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE VALUE BASS --
PROGRAMS ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IMPLEMENTING THE VALUE BASED
PAYMENT PROGRAM APPROVE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF A
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION TO PROVIDE
EARLY DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
FOR CHILDREN ADVERSE CHILDHOOD.
EXPERIENCES SCREENINGS FOR
CHILDREN ADULTSAND MEDI CAL
APPROVE EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY A
FIFTY MILLION TO TRAIN PROVIDERS
ON DELIVERING TRAUMA SCREENING
SENATE SENSITIVE APPROPRIATE
MANNER.
BROUGH EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR FAMILY
PLANNING SERVICES AND THE MEDI
CAL PROGRAM AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER LOOK BILL
LANGUAGE TO DIRECT THE FAMILY
PLANNING AUGMENTATION.
TO EVALUATION MANAGEMENT OFFICE
SERVICES PROCEDURES EDUCATION
AND COUNSELING AND VACCINATION
SPECIFIC TO A RELATED TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND FAMILY
PLANNING APPROVE EXPENDITURE
THIRTY OF TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
WORDS AND THE PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
APPROVED SPANISH AUTHORITY OF
THIRTY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR RESTORATION OF OPTICIAN AN
OPTICAL LAB SERVICES AUTHORIZED
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET
ACT AND REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED SUNSET
OF PROPERTY SIX INVESTMENTS ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX MEDI CAL PHARMACY SERVICES --
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE DIETZ YES PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING -- IMPLICATION OF
THE TRANSITION OF PHARMACY
BENEFIT TO FEE FOR SERVICE TO
ENGAGE QUARTERLY WAS
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY THAT MAY
BE IMPACTED BY THE TRANSITION TO
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSITION PLAN.
AND TO PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
FISCAL ANALYSIS OF THE COSTA
SAVINGS TO THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
AND TWO IMPACTED PROVIDERS.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHOLE PERSON
CARE HOUSING SERVICES PROVE IT'S
BUDGETED.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT NOT A WHOLE
PERSON CARE COUNTIES APPROVED
BUDGETED.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE CYBERSECURITY
PROGRAM AUGMENTATION APPROVES
BUDGETED ISSUE TEN ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD INCENTIVE PROGRAM
OUT ITS IMPROVE HIS BUDGET IT
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS STAFFING IS PROVE HIS
BUDGET IT ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
HOLD CHILD MODEL EVALUATION
CONTRACT FUNDING APPROVED THIS
BUDGET.
ISSUE THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA DENTAL
MEDICAID MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM CONTRACT MANAGEMENT
STAFFING APPROVES BUDGETED ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN CHILDHOOD LEAD
POISONING PREVENTION.
THIS BUDGET IT ISSUE NUMBER
FIFTEEN STRATTON STRENGTHENING
FISCAL ESTIMATES AND CASH FLOW
MONITORING.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE
REQUESTED POSITIONS AND
RESOURCES. FOR STRENGTHENING
FISCAL ESTIMATES AND CASH FOR
MONITORING AND ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
THE PART HEALTHCARE SERVICES TO
PROVIDE REGULAR UPDATES ON CASH
FLOWS THAT WOULD COMPARE.
ACTUAL SPENDING TO ESTIMATE
BUDGET AMOUNTS DEVELOPING
PRESENTED LEGISLATURE LONG TERM
PLAN WITH CHANGES TO BUDGETING
ACCOUNTING AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS THREATS TO
PROMOTE SOUND ESTIMATES AND
BUDGET TRANSPARENCY.
AND TO INITIATE A LEGISLATIVE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS INCLUDING
LEGISLATIVE STAFF IN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
INDEMNIFY POSSIBILITIES FOR
FUTURE CHANGES.
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN MEDI CAL
DRUG REBATE FUNDING.
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN MEDI CAL CHECK
RIGHT CONTINGENCY PAYMENTS ABOUT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE AS WITH THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN HEALTH HOLES
PROGRAM FUNDING EXTENSION ADOPT
PLACEHOLDERTRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CONSISTS OF THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN MANAGE
CARE SANCTIONS.
THAT DAHLE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE CONSISTENT WITH
THE MINISTRATIONS PROPOSALS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY MEDI CAL
OPTIONAL BENEFITS I RECOMMEND A
CRUCIAL EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF
TWENTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION TO
RESTORE THE FOLLOWING OPTIONAL
MEDI CAL BENEFITS AUDIOLOGY
INCONTINENCE CREAMS WASHES THE
DIE TREAT AND SPEECH LANGUAGE
AND THE DESERT SPEECH THERAPY.
TO ADOPT PLACER -- PLACEHOLDER
BILL THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO IMPLEMENT THE RESTORATION OF
THE FOLLOWING OPTIONAL MEDICAL
MEDI CAL BENEFITS AUDIOLOGY IN
CONDIT'S CREAMS WASHES PODIATRY
IN SPEECH THERAPY.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE UNUSUAL
OCCURRENCES COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS AND DISASTER
RESPONSE TO PROVE HIS BUDGET
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO DRUG
MEDI CAL CHAPTER LEGISLATION.
THIS BUDGET ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE S. A. P. T..
S. AT STANFORD [inaudible]
CPT. SEVENTY OKAY EXCEPT THE
BLOCK GRANT COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ENHANCEMENT APPROVE HIS BUDGET
IF YOU TWENTY FOUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT OVERSIGHT AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT.
THE PREVIOUS BUDGETED ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE FOSTER USE TROM
INFORM SYSTEMS OF CARE -- THIS
BUDGET ISSUE TWENTY SIX EARLY
PSYCHOSIS RESEARCH AND TREATMENT.
WE THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE TO
REJECT THE GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ALLOCATED TO DCS%
FOR EARLY PSYCHOSIS RESEARCH AND
TREATMENT BUT APPROVED GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE.
THREE OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION --
TWO FOUR MHS A DMO AT TO FUNDED
THE EARLY EXISTING EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION PLUS
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED BY A. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND THEN AT
THAT PLACE IT'S A STATUTES
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ABOUT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION PLUS
PROGRAM TO BE FUNDED FROM THE
STATE GENERAL FUND SO BASICALLY.
LOCATING IT AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH -- OVERSIGHT COMMISSION.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PRIVATE HOSPITAL DIRECTED
PAYMENT AND QUALITY INCENTIVE
POOL APPROVE THIS BUDGET ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES WAIVER PROGRAMS.
THE PROOF RECOMMENDED THAT THE
FONG ACTIONS TO PROVE REDUCTION
OF EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN. NINETEEN
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION IN. NINETEEN TWENTY
HUNDRED SIXTY POINT TWO MILLION
AND 202-020-2020. 202-122-0016
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND THREE TO FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION.
AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER AT THAT
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXPAND THE ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER THROUGH A PHASE
AND EXPANSION. 210-000-70050 SIX
LOTS BY MARCH FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE I JUST IN SUMMARY
THIS ACTUALLY.
SAVE MONEY AND THAT'S WERE SO
HAPPY ABOUT IT -- WE'LL SEE IF
WE THAT OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE STATE WHY TRANSITION PLAN
EXTENSION PROVES BUT IT IN
BUDGET IT.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY PROP FIFTY
SIX STAFFING APPROVES BUDGET
ISSUE THIRTY ONE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR ELDERLY
EXPANSION.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
THE REQUESTED POSITIONS AND
RESOURCES FOR EXPANSION OF PACE
PROGRAMS AND ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRE
PACE READY METHODOLOGY BE
DEVELOPED IN ACCORDANCE WITH
GENERALLY ACCEPTED ACTUARIAL
RATE DEVELOP PRINCIPLES AND
PROVIDE FOR ALL REASONABLE
PROPRIA TENABLE COSTS FOR EACH
PIECE ORGANIZATION WITHIN EACH
REGION.
CRUISE IS THAT PROVISION IN
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZING DTS IN
THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF
ADOPTION OF EXPERIENCE BASED
RATING TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO
RATES TO AVOID ADVERSE IMPACTS
ON PART PROVIDERS.
AND THREE REQUIRE RATES DURING A
PIECE ORGANIZATIONS FOR THREE
YEARS TO REFLECT THE LOWER
ENROLLMENT HIGHER OPERATING COST
ASSOCIATE WITH NEW PACE
ORGANIZATIONS.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY TO PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT WORKLOAD INCREASE
APPROVED BUDGETED ISSUE THIRTY
THREE OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
INCREASED WORKLOAD PROVES BUDGET
ISSUE.
THIRTY FOUR OF A QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS DRUG MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS TO PROVE HIS BUDGET
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE
REAPPROPRIATION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH MODERNIZATION RESOURCES.
FOR THIS BUDGET ISSUE THIRTY SIX
STRENGTHENING PREVENTIVE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN IN MEDIC
HAL APPROVES BUDGETED ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN PEER RUN MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS LINES A PREVIOUS
BUDGET IT ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT
VARIOUS RE APPROPRIATIONS.
APPROVED BUDGETED ISSUE THIRTY
NINE MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM
STAFFING APPROVED THIS BUDGET IT
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY I CAL FOR M.
L. I. S. OVERSIGHT OWNERSHIP.
SHIP AND MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
APPROVED BUDGET ISSUE -- FORTY
ONE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AB
EMERGING EPIDEMIC DISASTER
RESPONSE OF LICENSING WORKLOAD
APPROVES BUDGETED IF YOU FORTY
TWO LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ACTUARIAL STUDY.
APPROVED GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF A
MILLION TO FUND THE FEASIBILITY
STUDY IN ACTUAR ANALYSIS OF LONG
TERM SUPPORT SERVICES AND
FINANCING.
ISSUE FORTY THREE EXPAND
SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION
REFERRAL TO TREATMENT OF OF
PLEASE SUCH OTHER DRUGS.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION TO EXPAND THE
MEDI CAL BENEFIT FIRST BURKE TO
INCLUDE SCREENING FOR OVER USE
OF UP TO IT AND OTHER LISTEN
DRUGS.
AND TO ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SIX TO IMPLEMENT
THE EXPANSION OF SPUR TO OPIATES
AND OTHER ILLICIT DRUGS ISSUE
NUMBER.
FORTY FOUR SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELORS EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF TEN MILLION TO SUPPORT THE
HIRING OF HIGHLY TRAINED.
HIGHLY OF TRAINS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PEER NAVIGATORS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
NAVIGATORS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OF ACUTE HOSPITALS
ISSUE FORTY FIVE EXTENSION OF
MEDICARE FOR POST PARTUM MENTAL
HEALTH.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES THIRTY
OF EIGHT POINT SIX MILLION
ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT EXTENSION
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY FROM SIXTY
DAYS TO ONE YEAR. FOR POST
PARTUM WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH A
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER ISSUE
FORTY SIX METAL COOL
INTERPRETERS PILOT
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
FIVE MILLION TO IMPLEMENT A
PILOT PROJECT FROM MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS CONSISTENT WITH.
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY FIVE ISSUE
FORTY SEVEN CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO EXPLICITLY DEFINED
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIENTIAL
PROGRAMS A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
FACILITIES.
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID APPROVE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES -- FUND
OF ONE POINT SIX EIGHT MILLION
TO PILOT YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID TRAINING FOR TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL PERSONNEL DISTRICTS
WITH HIGH RATES OF SUICIDE WITH
HIGH POPULATIONS OF AT RISK
YOUTH.
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY NINE CLINICAL
LABORATORY REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY.
ADOPT LATER SOLD THEIR TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO LIMIT THE
STATUTORY CAP OF 80% OF MEDICARE
FOR CLINICAL LABORATORY RATES.
IN ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
ELIMINATION OF THE SENIOR
PENALTY FOR MEDI CAL AGED AND
DISABLED 210038%.
OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE ANNUAL
AND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR MILLION TO
EXPAND MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY FOR
AGING DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
210038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
AND THE TOP PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE EMPLOYMENT THE
CHANGE IN ENCOMPASSES
ELIGIBILITY FOR AGE AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS 210038% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL SO THOSE
ARE THE FIFTY ITEMS.
UNDER DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES A NEW STRUCTURE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THATWE HOLE
ITEM [inaudible]
ONE ITEM [inaudible]
THREE ITEM.
FOUR ITEM FIVE FOR A SPLIT UP IN
HAUTE -- ITEM -- NINETEEN I WANT
TO MOVE THE BALANCE BUT A QUICK
COMMENT ON ITEM TWENTY I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
A HIGH AND THE STAFF FOR
INCLUDING THE FORMALLY DELETED
SERVICES IN THE GREAT RECESSION
ESPECIALLY PODIATRY I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND OUR CITIZENS
ARE GONNA BENEFIT GREATLY FROM
THAT MOVE THE BALANCE.
THANK YOU SO -- WE HAVE
EXTRACTED ISSUES ONE THREE FOUR
FIVE IN NINETEEN THE AND WE A
FIFTY ISSUES OF THE REMAINDER OF
THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR.
STONE -- SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI RICARDO.
STONE.
OKAY.
RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH THE COUNT
YOUR SYSTEM INTEGRATOR.
THE THE MEDI CAL LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ESTIMATE MAY REVISION
UPDATE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR TADO --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T KNOW STONE.
OKAY SO THAT'S OUT.
TWO ZERO ISSUE NUMBER THREE'S
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL EXPANSION TO
UNDOCUMENTED YOUNG ADULTS WHICH
ALSO INCLUDES SENIORS.
AS OUR MOTION.
AS TO MOVE I CENTER TADO SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BY -- TOTO.
DON'T KNOW.
IF THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR TO
MANAGE CARE ENROLLMENT TAX --
MOTION. TO ME BY SERVICE CENTER
TADO SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND I DON'T KNOW.
STONE NO EIGHT THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE I
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO DIVIDE UP
THE THIS YEAR IF WE HEAR THIS --
EXCLUDES SEVEN AND EIGHT AND WE
CAN WITH THE BALANCE THAT WOULD
BE A PRO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL THAT THAT
THIS EXTRACT FOR SEPARATE VOTES --
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES AND
EIGHT IS THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
THAT -- SO THE REMAINDER OF
THOSE.
ITEMS -- YOU MOVED OKAY SO WE
ARE MOVING THE REMAINDER OF THE
ITEMS OF THAT PARTICULAR --
RECOMMENDATION IS ISSUE NUMBER --
FIVE SOCRATES CALL THE ROLL.
HI FOR TITLE STONE.
OKAY SO THOSE ARE OUT THREE ZERO
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP.
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE
EXPENDITURE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES.
THE MOTION. TO MOVE AYE SIR TADO
SECURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND FIGHT FOR TITLE STONE NO
DATE THAT'S OUT TO ONE AND THEN
THE PLACE HOLDER OF LANGUAGE --
COMPANY PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE.
THAT TO ME BY CENTER TADO --
SECULAR THESE CALL THE ROLL.
HI FOR TITLE STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT TO WHAT.
NOW THE MOVE ON DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT'S RIGHT NINETEENTH AT ST
THANK YOU SORRY OKAY AT ISSUE
NUMBER NINETEEN MANAGE CARE
SANCTIONS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO.
SIX OF THESE CALL THE ROLL AND
FIGHT FOR TOTAL.
STONE NO OKAY THAT'S OUT TO ONE
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WILL MOVE ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE ITEM ISSUES
UNDER THAT ITEM.
OKAY SO WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE EIGHT APPS MAY REVISION
ESTIMATE AND ESTIMATE AND
ADJUSTMENTS APPROVED THIS BUDGET
ISSUE NUMBER TWO HIV CARE
PROGRAM FINANCIAL ELIGIBILITY --
WE ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE CONSISTS OF THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL ISSUE
NUMBER THREE INFECTIONS.
FACTIONS DISEASE PREVENTION AND
CONTROL -- THE REGULATIONS TO
PROVE GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
FOUR MILLION FOR STATE
OPERATIONS AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE THE
GRANTS TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS A TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PREVENTION CONTROL AND
ADOPT PLACE HOLDER A BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRED DPH PROVIDE
THE GRANT FUNDS IN THE LUMP SUM
AVAILABLE FOR FOUR YEARS. TO
CREATE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
CONSULTATION LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTION TO ALLOCATE ONE
MILLION OF THE THIRTY SIX
MILLION LOCAL SYSTEMS GRANT.
FUNDING FOR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
ISSUE NUMBER FOR GENETIC DISEASE
GREEN PROGRAM A REVISION
ESTIMATES AND ADJUSTMENTS --
DOCTORS BUDGETED ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
PROGRAM A REVISION ESTIMATE
ADOPTED APPROVED BUDGETED.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING AND BLACK INFANT HEALTH
PROGRAMS FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE OVERALL
PROPOSED GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITATION PROGRAM AND
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM. TO
MAINTAIN THE PREVIOUS TOTAL FUND
ALLOCATIONS STATE OPERATIONS OF
TWO MILLION.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA VISITATION
PROGRAM AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM.
RE DIRECT GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES OFFSET BY FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS FOR STATE
OPERATION COSTS TO SIT TO
ADDITIONAL LOCAL ASSISTANCE
EXPENDITURES.
ABOUT PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO DIRECT.
THE PH TO ALLOW BLACK INFANT
HEALTH EXPENDITURES TO ALSO BE
UTILIZED BY LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS FOR PROGRAMS
IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
PERRY NEEDLE EQUITY INITIATIVE.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN PROP NINETY
NINE ADJUSTMENTS HEALTH
EDUCATION RESEARCH AND ALLOCATE
UNALLOCATED AMOUNTS APPROVES
BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
ALZHEIMER'S GRANT AWARDS IN
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON
ALZHEIMER'S PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS -- PROVES BUDGETED
ISSUE NUMBER NINE MATERNAL CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT HEALTH MEDI CAL
OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES APPROVES
BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER TEN CENTER
FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
LICENSING CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
FOR THIS BUDGET IT.
ISSUE NUMBER -- ELEVEN LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CONTRACT APPROVES
BUDGETING.
BUT IT'D ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
PREVENTION -- WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS TO PROVE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE OF
TWENTY MILLION ANNUALLY TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
CULTURE STATIONS FOR THE
PREVENTION OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
AND THE TOP PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO STRENGTHEN
STATUTORY GUIDELINES TO DPH ON
THE EFFECTIVE DISPERSAL OF LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN RICHMOND
LAD FOR LAB VIRAL RICKETTS
YOU'LL DISEASE LAB AND HAS BEEN
UPGRADE.
APPROVES BUDGETED ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN COMPREHENSIVE HIV
PREVENTION RESOURCES.
APPENDED TO PROVE GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE THIRTY OF TWENTY
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR GRANTS TO
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS IN
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATION FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HIV PREVENTION
RESOURCES.
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROPOSAL
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN ALZHEIMER'S
INFRASTRUCTURE -- MOTION IT
PREPARATIONS TO PROVE GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE OF TEN MILLION
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY FOR
GRANTS TO BUILD STATEWIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
EARLY DETECTION AND TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS.
AND INITIATE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS THROUGH COMMUNITY GRANTS
TO A PILOT COUNTIES CONSISTENT
WITH THAT PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM
FUNDING.
THE REGULATIONS TO PROVE GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND HALF A MILLION
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO INCREASE
STAFFING FIRM FORSMAN A PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES.
AND THE SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN LESBIAN
BISEXUAL AND QUEER MOMENTS
HEALTH.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE THIRTY
OF SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
IN NINETEEN TWENTY TO SUPPORT
LOCAL COMPREHENSIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS. TO ADDRESS L. B. Q.
WOMEN'S HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
TO FUND CHEN RESEARCH TARGHEE OP
Q. WOMEN'S HEALTH NEEDS AN
INVENTORY OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
CONSISTENT WITH PROPOSAL.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
MUSICIAN REGISTRY REGULATIONS
APPROVED GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION ANNUALLY TO
PROVIDE FULL FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA POSITION REGISTRY.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN INTEGRITY
OF FACILITY INSPECTIONS.
MOTION THAT REGULATIONS TO TOP
TRAILER PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW EMPLOYEES OF
ENTITIES INSPECTED Y DPH TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DISCUSS
POSSIBLE REGULATORY VIOLATIONS
ARE PATIENTS CITY CONCERNS WITH
INSPECTOR PRIVATELY DURING THE
COURSE OF INVESTIGATION SECTION.
THIS IS WHAT THE PROPOSAL ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY IS SET RANGE
ACCESS PROGRAM AMENDMENTS.
REGULATIONS ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUISHED UPDATE
CLARIFY REQUIREMENTS FOR SYRINGE
ACCESS PROGRAM AND ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE BEHAVIORAL RISK
FACTOR SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM.
REGULATIONS TO PROVE CHANCE FOR
FOUR AND A HALF MILLION.
BEFORE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND SORRY
NOW FOR HAVE MILLION FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FROM THE ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND RELATED DISORDERS
RESEARCH FUND FROM LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TO STAY OPERATIONS
ALLOWED DPH TO PARTICIPATE IN --
TWENTY TWENTY BEHAVE A RISK
FACTOR SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM
SURVEY ON SUBJECTIVE COGNITIVE
DECLINE.
ARE THERE EXTRACTIONS USEWAS
RETURNING THE OXYGEN.
THAT'S OKAY YOU DID A GREAT JOB
THANK YOU -- MISTER -- CHAIRMAN
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE PULL
ITEM OF ISSUE A LEVIN
[inaudible] SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND TWENTY AND ALMOST ABOUT. ONE
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY OKAY.
SO ISSUES NUMBER ELEVEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY HAVE BEEN
EXTRACTED THE REMAINING ISSUES
FOR THAT ONE THROUGH.
THE SET OF THE TWENTY ONE ISSUES
I'VE BEEN MOVED -- TO MICE
EXTRACTIONS -- BUT CENTER STONE
CIRCLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL RIGHT OR TITLE STONE.
I OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WHAT'S ON HERE. TO
OKAY SO -- THAT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS A
LESSON CONTROL LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CONTRACT TO MOTION MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR TADO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI FOR TITLE STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE OKAY NEXT ISSUE IS ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTEEN SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM FUNDING.
THE MOVE I CENTER TADA SIXTIES
HALL THE ROLE.
ANTI SADDAM STONE.
THAT'S OUT TO ONE ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN A LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN
CLEAR WOMEN'S HEALTH -- BY
SENATOR TADO SIXTY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
HI.
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TO ZERO AND THEN ISSUE NUMBER --
TWENTY SYRINGE ACCESS PROGRAM
AMENDMENTS. TO ME BY CENTER TADA
SIX OF THESE CALL THE ROLL.
HI FOR TOTAL STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT TO TWO ZERO OKAY.
RIGHT NOW THE MOVE TO THE
PARLIAMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
OF WHICH THERE ARE NINETEEN
ISSUES.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY PROGRAM UPDATES MAY
REVISION ADJUSTMENTS.
SO -- THE RECOMMENDATIONS
APPROVED THE BALANCE OF THE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT
PHARMACY HOSPITALS ESTIMATE AND
UPDATE FOR THE MAY.
REVISION WITH ANY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO CONFORM TO OTHER
ACTIONS HAVE BEEN OR WILL BE
TAKEN.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY PREVIOUS BUDGET
ISSUE NUMBER THREE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT CALIFORNIA STATE
LOTTERY FUND APPROVES BUDGET.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ENHANCE
TREATMENT SITE STATE WIDE
APPROVED BUDGETEDISSUE NUMBER
FIVE THAT'S GOOD THERE --
POSSIBLE WATER BOOSTER PUMP
SYSTEM.
THIS BUDGET IS ISSUE NUMBER SIX
METROPOLITAN CONSOLIDATION OF
POLICE OPERATIONS
REAPPROPRIATION APPROVE HIS
BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN PATTON
FIRE ALARM SYSTEM UPGRADE
REAPPROPRIATION APPROVES BUDGET
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT EXTENSION OF LIQUIDATION
PERIOD METROPOLITAN NAPA KITCHEN
PROJECTS PROVES BUDGETED ISSUE
NUMBER NINE RE OUT RELOCATION TO
THE CLIFFORD L. ALLENBY BUILDING.
APPROVES BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER TEN
VOCATIONAL SERVICES IMPATIENT
MINIMUM WAGE.
RECOMMENDATION IS -- TO APPROVED
IMPRESSIVE POSITIONS RESOURCES
INCLUDING MAY REVISION ESTIMATES
AT THAT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE CONSISTS OF THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO PROHIBIT
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS FROM
SWEEPING PATIENT FUNDS TO
SUPPORT HOUSING AND TREATMENT
COSTS.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT APPROVED BUDGETED
ISSUE TWELVE COURT EVALUATIONS
REPORTS A PREVIOUS BUDGET IT.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN DIRECT
CARE NURSING APPROVED THIS
BUDGET I ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
PHARMACY MARGE'S MODERNIZATION
APPROVES BUDGETED ISSUE FIFTEEN
VARIOUS TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
APPROVES BUDGETED.
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN INCREASE
COURT APPEARANCES IN PUBLIC
RECORDS ACTS REQUESTS APPROVES
BUDGET ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
PRIVACY PROTECTION PROGRAM FOR
THIS BUDGET.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN CONTRACTED
SUPPORTS AND MAN AND PATIENT
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT APPROVES
BUDGETED ISSUE NINETEEN
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
DIVERSION COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT -- THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO BUT THAT PLACE HOLDERS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
REQUESTING FOR THE PARMA STATE
HOSPITALS IN CONSULTATION WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE TEXT TO FIX
BY COUNTY ON THE UTILIZATION OF
NEW PRE TRIAL DIVERSION
AUTHORITY.
GRANTED THE COURTS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT INCLUDING
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS REQUESTING
PRE TRIAL DIVERSION NUMBER
QUESTS REPROVED AND NEVER
REQUEST DENIED A NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR THE NILES.
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETING
DIVERSION THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS NOT COMPLYING WITH
CONDITIONS OF THAT VERSION.
ARE THERE EXTRACTIONS
[inaudible]
ALL ISSUES.
NO OKAY THERE ARE NO EXTRACTIONS
IT'S A ISSUES NUMBER ONE TO
NINETEEN HAVE BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE US.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HER DAUGHTER.
STONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BUT OKAY [inaudible]
PALESTINIAN.
A LOT OF MONEY FOR SCHOOL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY NEXT UP.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY CONVINCED
COMMISSION.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE TRIAGE GRANT
FUNDING.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
BUT THE TWELVE MILLION ANNUALLY
TO RESTORE TRIAGE GRANT FUNDING
DOES REDUCE AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO COMMISSION
TRANSPARENCY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STAFFING STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVE FOR POSITIONS IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND OF
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION.
NINETY TWENTY AND TWENTY POINT
EIGHT MILLION ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
OVERSIGHT ADVISORY COMMISSION
PROPOSALS FOR DATA AN OUTCOME
REPORTING.
I'M GOING INNOVATION INCUBATOR
FUNDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
STAKEHOLDER CONTRACTS FOR
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE MENTAL
HEALTH.
AN S. P. -- TEN FOR FOR
OVERSIGHT MUNCHING ACTIVITIES.
QUESTION NUMBER.
THREE FEDERAL HEALTH SCHOOL
SERVICES ACT FUNDING.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE
CONFORMING ACTION TO ESTABLISH
TWO NEW ITEMS. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF FUNDING MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACT PROPOSAL.
ADOPTED IN BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
WHAT.
OUR EXTRACTIONS THIS FEATURE
RESPECTFULLY ALL ITEMS.
ISSUE THREE SHE THREE OKAY.
MOVE THE BALANCE.
RIGHT.
SO -- ISSUES BEEN EXTRACTED.
AND WILL BE MOVING ISSUES ONE
AND TWO MOVE BY. THREE THE
NUMBER TO THE LIST I'M SORRY MR
TRIPLE TO ALSO OKAY WILL EXTRAT
ISSUES TWO AND THREE TELL THE
ISSUE WHEN ONE HAS BEEN MOVED BY --
CENTER STONE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CAN I FOR TOTAL.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
THREE ZERO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO STYLE WHICH IS THE
COMMISSION TRANSPARENCY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE STAFFING
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS TO MOTION
BY SENATOR TADO SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BAND RIGHT OR TITLE STONE.
THAT'S OUT TWO ZERO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE MENTAL HEALTH -- SCHOOL
SERVICES ACT FUNDING.
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I WORKED OUT OF STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE NEXT IS THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE COVERED
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THREE ISSUES
THERE.
SO ISSUE ONE IS HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUM AFFORDABILITY.
MOTION DISAPPROVED
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY -- I WILL READ ALL
THIS TO PROVIDE PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES TO INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN
TWO HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED OF AT PO%
PURCHASING COVERAGE. FOR IN THE
STATE HELLO IT'S HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE AND TO AUGMENT THE
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES STORY
BY ADDING BY AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IN EACH YEAR.
FOR A TOTAL LEVEL OF PREMIUMS OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED THIRTY POINT
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
POINT NINE MILLION IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLAN TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WITHOUT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER A BRONZE
LEVEL PLANS AT HIGHER ACTUARIAL
VALUE TO COMPLY WITH NEW FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE SINGLE
PREMIUM INVOICE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL
REGULATIONS ABOUT PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE
STATUTORY CLARIFICATIONS REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS TO SEND
THE SINGLE INVOICING COLLECT ONE
PAYMENT FOR SUBSCRIBERS -- THE
OTHER EXTRACTIONS.
MISTER.
SPEAKER PLEASE EXTRACT ISSUE ONE
AND THREE OKAY.
WILL EXTRACT ISSUES ONE AND
THREE AND YOU MOVE ISSUE -- TO
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OUR DAUGHTER STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUM AFFORDABILITY.
THEN MOVE BY SENATOR TADO SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI FOR TITLE STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TWO ZERO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
SINGLE PREMIUM INVOICE TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL.
THE MOVE BY CENTER TODD ETCETERA
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND FIGHT
FOR TOTAL.
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES
PART EIGHT OF OUR AGENDA MORE
NOW MOVES. TO MOVE ON TO PART BE
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
YEAH
.
MOVING ON TO PART BE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH --
THE HEALTH AND HUMANSERVICES
AGENCY OFFICES IMMIGRATION
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS
ONLY ONE ISSUE WHICH OF US
PLEASE TRY AND VISIT
VERIFICATION.
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED AS
BUDGETED -- IS THERE A MOTION
ALL RIGHTS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE -- STARTED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR PAM HI UNDER TITLE.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO THE
PART OF AGING WITH THREE ISSUES
ISSUE ONE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ARGUMENTATION
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROVE THE NAY
REVISION AND ADDITIONALLY
APPROVE AN ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION IN. TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION EVERY YEAR THERE AFTER.
THE ISSUE NUMBER TWO DIGNITY A
HALL FALL DIGNITY AT HOME FALL
PREVENTION PROGRAM -- WITH THAT
SO THAT THE THAT THE MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE THE
PROPOSAL TO RECORD -- FOR FIVE
MILLION. FOR THE HEALTH FOR THE
PART AGING TO FUND THE PROGRAM
TO HELP OLDER ADULTS AND OTHERS
AT RISK OF FALLING TO MAKE HOME
MODIFICATIONS IT TAKES STEPS TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF FALLS AT HOME --
QUESTION NUMBER THREE IS
INCREASED FUNDING FOR SENIOR
EDUCATION PROGRAM -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO LOOK AT NOT
TO RECOUP TO HAVE AN ONGOING
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION.
INCREASE FUNDING TO FOR SENIOR --
NUTRITION PROGRAMS -- CARE ANY
EXTRACTIONS WATER THROUGH OKAY
SO -- ISSUES ONE THROUGH THREE
EVEN MOVE BY CENTER STONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN HI THEIR TITLE
THURSTON [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY A NEXUS DEPARTMENT OF ON
THE SERVICES WE HAVE THIRTEEN
ISSUES SO ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
HEADQUARTERS RESTRUCTURING AND
REORGANIZATION -- OF APPROVED
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED IS
BUDGETED -- ISSUE NUMBER TWO
FEDERAL CLAIMS REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM PROJECT -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROOF OF
THE FUNDING FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY ONLY AND THE TOP PLACE
HOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ON
ADDITIONAL COST SCOPE SCHEDULE
AND SCOPE INFORMATION BE
PROVIDED IN STAGES THREE AND
FOUR OF THE POWER PROCESS IS
PART OF THE PROPOSED. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE SAFETY NET
FACILITIES IN CRISIS SERVICES --
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE
HIS BUDGET AND ALSO.
APPROVE -- A PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RELATED TO SAFETY
NET FACILITIES THEY CUTE
SERVICES.
ACTUAL TEXT WEALTHIER THE PROOF
PLACEHOLDER TRAIL RELATES TO DO
THE FOLLOWING THE CARD
DEPARTMENT UPDATED CETINA PLANS
BE PROVIDED WITH THE JANUARY
RELEASE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. TO LINE I AM THE
ADMISSION CRITERIA POSTED
MISSION OVERSIGHT PROCESS FOR
JUDICIAL REVIEW WITH THE LAWS
GOVERNING PLACEMENTS A STATE
OPERATED KEEPS CRISIS SETTINGS.
AND A NOTIFY THE CLIENT RIGHTS
ADVOCATE WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL IS
PLACED IN A RESTRICTIVE SETTING.
SUCH ISSUE NUMBER THREE ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHT CBS FINALS
RULE SITE ASSESSMENTS -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO THE
PREVIOUS BUDGETED AND ALSO AT
APPROVED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTS THE NEW
IT'S BS RULES CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE FOSTER YOUTH --
TRAUMA INFORMED SYSTEMS OF CARE --
SPRING FINANCE LETTER -- PROVES
BUDGETED ISSUE NUMBER SIX CRISIS
HOMES FOR CHILDREN.
REGULATIONS TO PROVE PLACE
HOLDER A LANGUAGE -- PER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN SPECIALIZED%
CASELOAD RATIOS TO REGIONAL
CENTERS -- PROVED PLACEHOLDER
LANGUAGE PER GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT HI MAY
REVISION ADJUSTMENTS -- AND DO
WE RE RECOMMENDING -- THE
FOLLOWING ACTIONS [inaudible]
REGARDS. TO THOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
PART OF OUR WITH THE LOCAL
SERVICES -- SO A POPULATION
STAFFING ADJUSTMENT APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET.
EARLY START COPAYMENTS APPROVE
THIS PROPOSED AND FOOD RELATED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
FAMILY HOME AGENCY OVERSIGHT.
APPROVED AS PROPOSED A
SPECIALIZED HOME MONITORS
APPROVE THIS PROPOSED.
CASELOAD AND UTILIZATION
ADJUSTMENT APPROVE THIS PROPOSED
PROVIDER RATE ADJUSTMENT REJECT
THE SUNSET DATE AND APPROVE ON
AN ONGOING BASIS.
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
SUSPENSION REJECT THE SUNSET
DATE THEM PERSONALLY REPEAL THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
AND BEST BUDDIES APPROVED AS
PROPOSED.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN REGIONAL CENTER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT
PLEASE HOLD TO ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. TO
ADDRESS -- TO ADDRESS OTHER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ISSUES INCLUDING REQUIRED
DEPARTMENT THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE TO IDENTIFY AND TRACK KEY
INDICATORS OF REGIONAL CENTERS
SYSTEMS DELIVERY OF SERVICES AS
WELL AS A PLAN FOR REPORTING OF
BEST PRACTICES RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR MEASURING APPROVING.
CONSUMER OUTCOMES DEPARTMENT
pBEST PRACTICES RECOMMENDATIONS
IN A REPORT TO LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE EACH IT REGIONAL CENTER
TO POSE SPECIFIC INFORMATION A
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
FINAL RULEIT'S WEBSITE.
REQUIRED DEPARTMENT AND ONLY
UPDATE THE LEGISLATURE OF
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON THE
FILING AND RESOLUTION COMPLAINTS
AND FAIR HEARING REQUEST FILED
WITH EACH REGIONAL CENTER.
REQUIRED DEPARTMENT EACH
REGIONAL CENTER AND INCLUDE A
LINK TO THE PROTECTION AND
ADVOCACY AGENCY IN CLIENT RIGHTS
ADVOCATE IN A CENTER LOCATION
WEBSITE REQUIRED DEPARTMENT
OPPOSED ALL NEW DIRECTIVES.
ISSUED TO REGIONAL CENTERS ON
ITS WEBSITE REQUIRED REGIONAL
CENTERS PROVIDE A LIST OF AGREED
UPON SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE
CONSUMERS AT THE CONCLUSION OF
AN INDIVIDUAL.
PROGRAM PLAN MEETING REQUIRED TO
REGIONAL CENTERS REPOSE TO POST
SPECIFIC POLICIES GUIDELINES
PROTOCOLS ASSESSMENT TOOLS ON
OUR WEBSITE.
ISSUE NUMBER.
ELEVEN TOM THE EXPANSE BEHAVIOR
SUPPORTS HOMES SUNSET EXTENSION --
PROVE HIS PROPOSED.
THE ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE VENDOR
RATE REFORM -- SENATE PROPOSAL.
INCLUDES AT RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
REQUIRING DEPARTMENTS SUBMIT A
PLAN FOR STATEWIDE RATE REFORM
CONSIDERING THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE RATE STUDY
AN IMPENDING.
H. CBS FINAL RULES -- WITH
STAKEHOLDER INPUT BY JANUARY
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE
PLAN BEGINNING IMPLEMENTATION
DATE NO LATER THAN JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE KILL THE HALF
DAY BILLING POLICY APPROVED
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ALLOW VENDORS IN AREAS
WHERE THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE IS
HIGHER THAN THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE.
ACCESS TO READ ADJUSTMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH STATE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES.
PEARLY REPEALED THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AS MENTIONED
BEFORE.
RESTORE SOCIAL RECREATION AND
CAMP SERVICES ADOPT PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS CHANGE.
AND APPROVED A MAJOR REVISION
PROPOSAL FOR PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENT ELIMINATE THE
PROPOSED SUNSET -- IS THE
PREVIOUS MENTION.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN CODIFIED
DDS QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS -- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CODIFY THE FAR
MENTAL BRIEFINGS IN STATUTE.
SO THOSE ARE THIRTEEN ISSUES
EXTRACTIONS.
PLEASE MISTER TERRIFIC A POLE
NUMBER FOUR SHE NUMBER FOUR
THANK YOU AND I'M WITH THE
BALANCE OKAY SO WE'RE THAT --
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR IS EXTRACTED
OF ISSUES ONE THROUGH --
THIRTEEN IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE.
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible] THIRTEEN BY --
TITLE.
I'VE CENTER STONE.
A THOSE ARE OUT THREE ZERO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR EIGHT CBS FINAL RULE
SITE ASSESSMENTS.
OUR MOTION.
OKAY -- MOVED -- PROVABLE --
THIS SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER PAN HI THURSTON THE THIRD
ITEM [inaudible]
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT TWO ZERO LANDER
SANDERS A MOTION CENTER STONE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL MOTION UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES THE MOTION IS TO
REQUEST A SUBCOMMITTEE ADOPT.
AN AUGMENTATION OF TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO FUND AN 8%
PROVIDER RATE INCREASE AND ALL
RATE CATEGORIES FOR PURCHASE OF
SERVICES AND COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS.
EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN EXCEPT FOR
THOSE SERVICE CATEGORIES THAT
WOULD RECEIVE A RATE INCREASE IN
TO THE GOVERNOR'S.
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL THE RATE
INCREASES WOULD BE IN PLACE
UNTIL THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
IMPLEMENTS ITS COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS RESULTING FROM IT'S
REACHED ANY APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WITH CONSULTATION.
AND INPUT FROM APPROPRIATE
STAKEHOLDERS.
A DIM MIND.
AT TWO SIXTEEN MILLION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I WAS -- WE ARE TRYING TO CHECK
ON THE AMOUNT OF OF THAT -- OKAY
SO JUST TO CLEAR OKAY SO THE
MOTION IS FOR A 8% -- THE OKAY
RATE. 8% PROVIDER RATE INCREASE
IN ALREADY CATEGORIES FOR
PURCHASE INTO IT EXCEPT FOR THE
SERVICE CARRIES TO RECEIVE A
RATE INCREASE UNDER THE GUMS MAY
RECIPROCATE I DO TO MAKE IT THE
HIGHER OF WHATEVER STAFF
DETERMINES.
A IN A MINIMUM BUT THE AMOUNT IS
A LIFE BUT IN THE MOTION OF THAT
IS NOW THAT'LL THEM CRITICAL
ISSUE.
TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT THE MOTION
BEFORE -- SURE I I THINK WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF CONTRACTORS PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
FOR OUR DEVELOPMENT DISABLED AND
FRANKLY THE HOW WERE HIT DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WE HAVE NOT --
INCREASE THOSE RATES WE HAVE A
PROVIDER STUDY THIS TAKEN A
COUPLE YEARS WHICH ARE -- GOING
TO HOPEFULLY -- GET THEM THE THE
THE FEES THAT THEY THEY NEED AND
DESERVE AND THIS IS JUST A UP TO
A TEMPORARY SHOW OF GOOD WILL TO
SHOW THAT WE APPRECIATE THEIR
SERVICES.
UNTIL WE CAN.
FULLY DEFINE WHAT THOSE RATE
INCREASES WILL BE AN
RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR ABOUT.
OKAY WELL -- THE THE THEM THE
MOTION CENTER STONE I I WOULD
WANT TO FIRST OF ALL -- POINT
OUT THAT -- WE ARE -- THE WALLS
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE -- ALSO JUST
ADOPTED ACTUALLY -- FOR OUR SUB
COMMITTEE -- SEVERAL INCREASES --
FOR THE TO TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES -- I ALSO WANT -- TO
CLARIFY THAT SO I COULD DO IS I
WOULD SAY READ THE MOTION THAT
SO BASICALLY THAT'S FOR SERVICES
THAT ARE NOT RECOMMENDED FOR THE
INCREASE -- BY THE GOVERNOR --
SAID YES WE HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASE AND WE HAVE AND WILL
ACTUALLY WE DO INTEND.
TO LOOK AT THE THE RATE STUDY I
THINK I'VE MENTIONED -- TO BOTH
YOU AND CENTER TODD -- WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF THE RATE
STUDY -- WE ARE LOOKING AT
PROPOSING -- THE AND IN TERMS OF
BEING SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO FOLLOW
UP ON THE RATE STUDY BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT SEED NOW --
THIS THIS PROPOSAL ISN'T QUITE --
YELP.
IN THE THE STRUCTURE THAT -- SO
THAT -- WE HAVE PROPOSED-- BUT
CERTAINLY I THINK YOU KNOW WE'VE
HEARD.
FROM FOLKS AND AND CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE -- THAN THE NEED
THAT'S THERE -- AND I KNOW THAT --
CENTER TANTO SPOKEN TO THAT AND
YOU'VE SPOKEN TO THAT AND I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT AS WELL -- SO --
BUT AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
UP THE MOTION -- I THINK THE
SERVER TAUGHT AS AS DID YOU DO
YOUR TO MAKE A CLASSIC AT THE
STATION YEAH [inaudible]
CATION.
YES SO -- WHAT ABOUT EIGHT BALL
ACTUALLY?
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION ON 48% ACROSS THE BOARD --
EXCEPT FOR THERE IS A GREATER
INCREASE -- BUT LEAVING IT UP TO
THE FINAL BUDGET OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO.
SO WHAT I HEAR SO IT'S OF
BECAUSE I THINK YOUR MOTION
THAT'S WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE MOTIONS HERE SO MY MOTION
WAS AT THE THE GOVERNOR GAVE IN
THE MAY BE REVISED RIGHT HE GAVE
HER AT A GORY CITY RIGHT
INCREASED BY MORE THAN A PERCENT.
AND I WAS AND HE DIDN'T INCREASE
THE OTHER SERVICES THAT.
MANY OF WHICH ARE VERY IMPORTANT
I SAID LET'S REYES ALSO THE
BALANCE UP 8% JUST TO OKAY HELLO.
CENTER I'M NOT SURE WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT POLLS ARE ACTUALLY
RAISED.
EVERYONE AT THE EVEN THE FOCUSED
ONE AT LEAST 8% I SEE LA --
SHAKING HER HEAD SO SO YOU SO
YOUR MOTION IS TO BE SURE THAT
EVERYONE AT LEAST HAS AN 8%
INCREASE EVEN FOR THE AREAS
WHERE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED AN
INCREASE.
SO OKAY SO RIGHT SO I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
CLARIFICATION OKAY SO WE WILL BE
SURE OF ONE GETS AT LEAST A
MINUTE MEETING BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH AREAS FOR THE GOVERNOR OF
PROPOSE WHICH WE DID ADOPT.
NOT NECESSARILY 8% THAT DAY I
GOT I GOT SOME NOTS HERE OKAY.
OKAY SO GOOD SO WE WANT TO BE
SURE WE CATCH THE RIGHT THING
OKAY SO SO LET'S GO SO.
ALRIGHT SO WHAT WE GO AHEAD AND
MOVE CENTER TAUGHT AS MOTION
WHICH IS A MINIMUM 8% INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
RIGHT I DON'T BE SURE TO GET
YOUR MOTION CORRECTLY WITH A
WHAT IS THE MINIMUM 8% ANDOF
COURSE IF THERE'S A GREATER AN
8%.
WE ARE GOING -- TO THIS PROPOSED
BY THE PREVIOUS ACTIONS ARE WE
JUST TALKING THE GOVERNOR IS AND
THAT INCREASE OF COURSE WILL IN
EXCESS OF A PERCENT WOULD OF
COURSE CONTINUE TO BE APPROVED
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE A GOOD LUCK WITH
A FIVE OKAY GOOD SO -- THE WILL
TAKE UP THE MOTION BY SENATOR
TADO -- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAM.
HI BUT TITLE CENTER STONE HI
THANK YOU OKAY.
WE HAVE PASSED THAT OUT THREE
ZERO AND YOU'LL CROSS OUR
FINGERS.
OKAY.
THERE YOU GO.
NOW HAVE TO EXPLAIN.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE PARTNER
REHABILITATION THANK YOU CENTER --
HURTADO FOR CATCHING CLARIFYING
THAT OKAY SO THE THE PART
MINISTRY VISITATION SO WE HAVE --
OKAY.
WE HAVE YOUNG AT TAKE OKAY WILL
HAVE ONE ISSUE -- SUPPORT
EMPLOYMENT PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENTS AND REYES.
A REVISION -- OKAY SO AND THAT
IS A PROOF BUT ELIMINATE TO
PROPOSE SUNSET TO MAKE IT ON
GOING.
AT IT IS THERE ANY EXTRACTION
THAT I OKAY SO THE ITEMS BEEN
MOVED.
SOCRATES CALL THE ROLL.
PETER PAN HI -- TITLE CENTER
STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO NEXT
TO THE PAR REHABILITATION AND
THE PART OF AGING -- ONE ISSUE --
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR THE NO
WRONG DOOR MODEL WHICH IS A
SEQUEL TO PROPOSAL TO REQUEST
FIVE MILLION AND I'M GOING
FUNDING TO EXPAND THE USE OF NO
WRONG DOOR MODEL WITHIN TH
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
ANY EXTRACTION.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
STONE -- SECURITIES CALL THE
ROLL.
PETER PAN HI ENTER TITLE.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO OKAY
DEPARTMENT OF SUCH CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES -- WE HAVE TWO ISSUES
ISSUE NUMBER ONE LOCAL CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING ARGUMENTATION -- THE THE
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AND THE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S FUNNY
PROPOSAL PROPOSAL IN ADDITION A
TOP PLAY SELECTION THE BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CLARIFY THAT
THE CURRENT COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDING METHODOLOGY
WOULD ONLY APPLY IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY WITH THE
EXPECTATION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
STAKEHOLDER INPUT WOULD PROPOSED
UPDATES TO THE MYTHOLOGY TO THE
METHODOLOGY IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY A PROVIDE SUMMARY OF THE
DISCUSS PROGRAMMATIC POLICY
CHANGES AND OUTLINED POTENTIAL
IMPACTS.
ISSUE TO IS THE MATE REVISION
ESTIMATES WHICH WE RECOMMEND --
PROOF APPROVAL AS PROFESSOR ANY
EXTRACTIONS OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER STONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FREE SHE'S WANTED.
TO CENTER PAN.
YOUR DATA CENTER STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT THREE ZERO NEXUS
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES -- WE
HAVE FORTY TWO ISSUES I WILL
MENTION THAT ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
IS -- ACTUALLY WAS A DUPLICATE
SO -- WE WILL NOT -- WILL REMOVE
ISSUE THIRTY AS A DUPLICATION.
SO THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
GET TWICE AS MUCH MONEY SEVEN
TWICE.
OKAY.
GO SURE EXTRA BRIGHT PICTURE
[inaudible]
OUR RATE.
OKAY ISSUE ONE DATA MIGRATION
FOR LEGACY SYSTEMS -- APPROVES
BUDGETED IT WAS AN ADDITIONAL.
PLACE HOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE CRYING DEPARTMENT THE
REPORT PACK BACK ON ACTUAL COSTS
AND JUST FUNDING LEVELS
ACCORDINGLY.
ISSUE TO CWS CARES APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED.
ISSUE THREE CAL SAWS
ARGUMENTATION ABUSE APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED MAY REVISE ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR MAY REVISION CASE THE JUST
MONTHS APPROVE THIS PROPOSED TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS -- APPROVE THIS
PROPOSED ISSUE NUMBE -- SIX
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE CASPER'S
MINUTES.
APPROVE THIS PROPOSED ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN RAPID RESPONSE
FUNDING -- APPROVED BUT PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION FOR
THE RAPID WRISTS SPOTS RESERVE
IN ADDITIONALLY ADOPT PIECE THE
HOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
MOVING THE FUNDS FROM THE PART
OF FINANCE TO DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT EXPENSIVE
IMMIGRATION RELATED SERVICES --
APPROVED AS A PROPOSED.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE ADMINISTRATION
OF REFUGEE SERVICES -- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE APPROVED AS
PROPOSED.
NOT.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TEN RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL ADMINISTRATION
AND BACKLOG -- THIS PROPOSED.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL.
AND EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
PAYMENTS RECOMMENDATIONS
APPROVED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS TO PRIOR
PRIOR TO RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL FOR UP TO A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS.
OR UP TO THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS IF THE COUNTY PROVIDES
GOOD BECAUSE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH -- TWENTY TWENTY ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWELVE FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND SUPPORT -- APPROVE
THIS PROPOSED TO MUTE MAY
REVISED -- ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THE PENSACOLA SO TITLE FOR E.
FUNDING APPROVE THIS PROPOSED.
BUDGET A CURTAIN WEEK ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN CUTTING INTO CUT
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
CONTRACTS APPROVES PROPOSED
ISSUE NUMBER.
FIFTEEN BRING FAMILY'S HOME --
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED THE MAY
REVISE AND ADDITIONALLY APPROVED
TEN MILLION ONE TIME FOR THE
PROGRAM.
ISSUE NMBER SIXTEEN CAN GAP
BEGINNING DATE OF AID -- THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE APPROVE
THIS PROPOSED ISSUE SEVENTEEN
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM MAYOR VICE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WITH DOT A PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN EXPANDING
HOW FAST RECIPIENTS OF SS I
CLEAN UP -- WILL DIE REGULATIONS
TO DOT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION FUNDING
FOR EXPANDED CAO FRESH
POPULATION.
RELATIONS APPROVE THIS PROPOSED
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY COUNTY WORK NUMBER
CONTRACT TO PROVE HIS PROPOSED.
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE RECOMMENDATION.
SHIPPING.
WITHIN THE FUNDING ABOUT
[inaudible]
PROPOSED [inaudible]
COME.
THEN THE FUNNY MOUNT THOSE BY
THE GOVERNOR OF THREE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION.
ADOPT A MODIFIED GRANT INCREASE.
TO REYES GRANTS 250% THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL FOR SYSTEM UNITS
OF ONE AND 48% FOR ALL OTHER A
USED TOWARD THE GOAL OF ENDING
DEEP POVERTY. FOR ALL THIS IS AN
UNITS.
A PLUS ONE PER TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET AGREEMENT ADOPT
A SOLDIER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
EMPLOYMENT THIS CHANGE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO HOME
VISITATION PROGRAM.
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S J. IN
MAY JANUARY MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS.
AND ADDITIONALLY TOP LOW COST
PLACE OLD TRIP BILL LANGUAGE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO ALL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN AGED.
ZERO TO TWO IF YOU TWENTY THREE
CAO WORK STAGE ONE TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY.
MAKE THE FOLLOWING CHANGES TO
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL.
PROVIDE TWENTY FIVE THE HAVE
PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE PROPOSAL
IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDING
PROVIDED A REVISION.
PROPOSED STABILITY AND
FLEXIBILITY OF CARE FOR OUR SPAM
THESE BY AUTHORIZING FULL TIME
CONTINUOUS CHILD CARE AND STAGE
ONE THE FAMILIES ARE TRANSFERRED
STAGE TWO OR FOR TWELVE MONTHS
AND COUNTIES WERE DISABILITIES
ACHIEVE AFTER TWELVE MONTHS.
SPECIFIED DIGITAL PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES FOR WHICH CHILD CARE
IS AVAILABLE TO PARENTS AND TIME
DURING WHICH PARENTS SHOULD BE
OFFERED CARE NOR TO PARTICIPATE
STERN ACTIVITIES.
AND FUND THE DATA SHARING SYSTEM
BETWEEN COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENTS CHILD CARE
CONTRACTORS TO ENSURE CHILD CARE
IS NOT DISRUPTED DURING TRANSFER.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR CAL
LEARN CASE MANAGEMENT STANDARDS
CHANGE PROVED HIS PROPOSED.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE DECREASE TEN
OF FUNDING FOR CAL GRANTS
APPROVED SUPPOSE AS PROPOSED.
TWENTY SIX HOURS HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM THE APPROPRIATION
APPROVE THIS PROPOSED ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
TERMINOLOGY CHANGE AND THE PLATE
THE LATE OF LIMITATION.
DOT PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE.
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT I TO ASSESS
THE MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT.
RECOMMENDATIONS APPROVED MAY
REVISION ADJUSTMENTS THE HSS
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
ADDITIONALLY THE OP PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REDUCE THE
COUNTIES HI TO ASSESS
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT ANNUAL
INFLATION FACTOR 24%.
ONLY ONE A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT IS IN PLACE IN WHICH
THE NEGOTIATED WAGE FOR THE AYE
JUSTICE PROVIDER.
PROVIDERS IS AT LEAST ABOVE THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
ISSUE.
TWENTY NINE ELIMINATE
FINGERPRINT LICENSING FEE
EXEMPTION APPROVES PROPOSED
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY AS I
MENTIONED IS A DUPLICATE -- WE
WILL.
NOT HAVE FULL DELETE.
ISSUE THIRTY ONE CODIFY EBV
PROTECTIONS -- DOT PLEASE HOLD
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THE KIND OF HIGH -- OF
THE PLATONIC VERIFICATION THAT
PROTECTIONS IN THE TWENTY
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET.
IF YOU.
THIRTY TWO FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM -- APPROVE.
THE REQUEST FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
AND THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THIRTY MILLION ON GOING TO
SUPPORT FOSTER USING CARE GIVERS --
IT -- FOR THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
ISSUE.
THIRTY THREE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD -- THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AT THAT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CHANGE
THE CURRENT.
AND EARNED INCOME DISREGARD TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND 50% OF
INCOME WITH THE JUNE FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY EFFECTIVE DATE
ALLOWING SUBSEQUENT ADJUSTMENTS
IN FUTURE FISCAL YEARS.
THE THIRTY FOUR APS AND PUBLIC
GUARDIAN TRAINING -- APPROVED
THE REQUEST. FORTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
OVER THREE YEARS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR A PS
SOCIAL WORKER TRAINING.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE ADDRESSING THE
IMPACT THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE ON
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES.
OF A ONE TIME CNI BASED KOLOFF
FOR FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY RATES
FOR OPERATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
IF YOU THIRTY SIX CODIFICATION
OF THE CC OUR QUARTERLY UPDATES --
THE PROPOSAL'S ADOPT PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
TO INCLUDE THE COMPONENTS
UPDATES OF TRANSITION PROVIDERS
TO THE CEASE YOUR SERVICE MODEL
UPDATES ON CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TRACKING
PRODUCT OUTCOMES CHILD OUTCOMES
OVERTIME AND UPDATES ON CC ARE
RELATED COST SAVINGS.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN PER
MINUTE RESTORATION THE 7% CUT
AND I JUST A SERVICE HOURS --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REMOVE STATUTORY
REFERENCES ITIS A SERVICE OUR
REDUCTIONS IN REJECT THE SUNSET
PROPOSAL IN THE MAY REVISION ON
THE RESTORATION.
ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTY EIGHT OBSOLETE REPORTS
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE TOP
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REMOVE STATUTORY
REFERENCES. TO REFER TO THE
REPORTS AS DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AS A REFER TO PROGRAMS THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS WERE NEVER
IMPLEMENTED A REPLACED BY OTHER
UPDATED IMPORT REQUIREMENTS AND
I WILL JUST REFER PEOPLE TO THE
RIGHT OF THE LISTING ALL THE
REPORTS.
ISSUE THIRTY NINE CAL FOOD
STORAGE AND TRANSPORTATION RATE --
APPROVE THIS PROPOSED FOR A
TRAIN INCREASE IN THE STORAGE
AND TRANSPORTATION RATE 215%.
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY SAFETY NET
RESERVE.
APPROVE THIS PROPOSED -- FOR THE
DEPOSIT SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
INTO THE SAFETY NET RESERVE.
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY ONE S. S. T.
GRANTS A SET UP A MERRY PAYMENT
GRANTS -- RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVE THE PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE A
CALL OUT TO THE STATE PORTION OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
STATE SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENT
GRANT ON A ONE TIME BASIS
BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY FOR AN ISSUE FORTY TWO A
GROUP HOME EXTENSION TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. TO PROVE A
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- REGARDING A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE EXISTING
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
GRUPO PROVIDERS TO CONVERT TO
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT --
PROGRAMS LICENSURE.
ARE THERE ANY EXTRACTIONS
RESPECTIVELY -- REQUEST WE PULL
ITEM SEVEN A SEVEN EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT AND MOVED THE BALANCE OKAY.
SO WE'RE EXPECTING ISSUE SEVEN
EIGHT AND TWENTY EIGHT WE HAVE
ISSUES ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN SO --
WE WILL AT CENTER STONE MOVES
THE REMAINING ISSUES -- SOCRATES
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN BY THEIR DAUGHTER.
CENTER STONE.
A THOSE ARE OUT THREE ZERO THAT
WE CAN GO BACK TO DISTRACTED I
WAS ISSUE NUMBER -- SEVEN WHICH
IS THE SPECIALIZED KEYS FOR IT
RAISED LOAD RATIOS FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS.
HELLO SORRY.
FRONT PAGE CLINTON I GOT A
FLIPPING BACK AND FORTH OKAY SO
SORRY ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
RAPID RESPONSE FUNDING -- THIS
IS OUR MOTION.
THE NEW BY CENTER TADA
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR BAM BY.
SENATOR DONALD.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT.
TWO ONE A NEXUS ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT EXPENSIVE IMMIGRATION
RELATED SERVICES.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER PAN HI -- TADA THURSTONE.
STATE THAT'S ABOUT TWO ONE ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT IT.
HI TO ASSESS MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT.
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY US --
SENATOR TADO SECURITIES CALL THE
ROLL -- PAN HI THERE TARA.
THE CENTER STONE NO THAT'S OUT.
TO ONE I THINK THE THAT
CONCLUDES UR AGENDA FOR FOR
PART B. AGAIN I WANT TO THANK.
MY SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS --
CENTER STONE ANSWER TADO FOR
YOUR VERY HARD WORK -- THIS IS --
I THINK THIS COMMITTEE PROBABLY
HAS THE MOST EXTENSIVE AGENDAS
AM I DON'T I'M ACTIVELY OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS DOLLARS BUT
I THINK WE CAN RESERVE A CLAIM.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU I ALSO I THINK ALL THE
STAFF AND ALL THE PEOPLE HERE.
YOU MISTER SENATOR PAN AND
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU AND OF COURSE ALL
RIGHT WHAT THAT -- WE HAVE
COMPLETED GENDER -- AND SO WITH
THE STATE'S HEARING OF THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IS A